challenging is how some have labeled it
we've been told supply is limited
despite this
many first-time homeowners are eager to
transition from renters
to homeowners and a growing number of
these first-time buyers
are latino whose homeowner rates have
increased more in recent years
than other ethnic groups
even the kitchen i am so thankful you
know every time i walk in there just
because i know that
the effort and the sacrifice that we did
to to make it happen
alejandra caldera can't stop smiling
after achieving what many latinos say
is the ultimate american dream owning a
home
i literally open up the windows i think
it's a lot of misconceptions
that it's too expensive or
you know that you're not really aware of
the type of programs and assistance that
there is available
after years of renting this las vegas
family took a leap of faith
and focused on home stability we had a
tough financial
spot and our credit was super bad so we
had zero savings so we knew like
we were broke we can't buy a home
another major hurdle was her husband's
legal status
caldera says he had all his documents
but no credit history
it was harder so another our income as
married would not count with his itin
because it was just me because you have
to have the social for
um for the closing for like the mortgage
for the financing aspect
or you didn't qualify for certain
programs according to lending patterns
nevada
ranks fifth in the nation with states
with the biggest share of mortgages made
to hispanic homeowners
who have faced challenges from not
having enough for a down payment
to high home prices realtor alex vasquez
says
there are programs to help first-time
home buyers like the nevada housing
program
and the caldera family is one of many
who are benefiting from these
it varies on a case-by-case christian
but there's
down payment assistance programs of
course to help but other than that
there's programs that you can get into
with as little as three percent down
so you're talking an average purchase
price of three hundred thousand dollar
home
um you're talking as little as nine
thousand dollars out of pocket
it's no secret the number of latinos are
growing with an estimate
of 60 million in the u.s according to
the census bureau
about 40 percent of hispanic home buyers
are under 34 years old
vasquez says the housing market is very
attractive to buyers right now
because of low interest rates we
definitely recommend buying now
uh christian and only because interest
rates are at historic lows
which make uh mortgage uh opportunity
or payments rather affordable in many
cases we're seeing with
with these low interest rates that for
families
it's more affordable to to purchase than
to rent
he says the first step to buying a home
is getting in touch with a professional
realtor
an easy step for this family i always
had this picture of what i wanted in a
home i wanted to have horses
i want to be able to have animals more
than 40 percent of latinos tend to
purchase fixer-upper homes according to
the national association of hispanic
real estate professionals
that was the case for the caldera family
that closed in august
on 280 thousand dollar home in north las
vegas
it's not just the look it's like the
lifestyle my husband's the charo
so he's like all about that country
living three months later the home was
remodeled and even made some space for
their horse spirit
several goats chickens and other pets at
first it's kind of weird you know we
always say let's pay let's pay the rent
we have to pay the rent
and i was like wait this is ours like we
have to pay our mortgage so
it does because you're so used to
renting
that when it's yours you're like oh man
this is mine and it but it's a great
feeling
according to data from lending patterns
the share of mortgages made to hispanic
homeowners has been
on the rise for the past eight years as
for advice the caldera family learned
that researching and asking plenty of
questions
was key we have more information on
programs available for first-time
homebuyers
on our website 8newsnow.com christian
casadas 8 news now
you